Mình chỉ thật chính, hồi đồng bỏ anh hợp quốc đã bắt dự thẳng nghĩ quét để sốt dự bỏ việc viện
các lãnh Trung phát lối với Iran theo đồ trong cuộc bỏ phíao này, có ngà Trung Quốc và
Khi Stang và Anzari, ông Hộ dự thảo, hãy nước bỏ phíao chẳng trong khi chính thành viên bỏ phíao chống.
Thuy nhiên, tây hiên và các cường của Châu Âu vận còn tạm ngày để tiếp tục đầm phán về việc phán
giải kích hoạt các bạn phát Trung phát. Kèo quyết trình dò anh phát và lực, hay còn gọi là nhóm
em và sợ đồng, người hay em tạm tham tạm. Hôm nay, đồng bỏ anh hợp quốc cần bỏ phíao về dự thảo trên sau khi em và
khởi động gơ chế bà mình ai nhằm tại áprat các lệ trường phát của liên Quốc. Nhóm em và
các buộc Iran không tôn thủ thật măng tên kể hoạt thành độ trường tỏng diện VCPOA,
tìm mà tây hiên răng đạo ki về nhóm phê năm có một gồm anh pháp, Mỹ, ngà Trung Quốc và
đất, hồi năm 2018, chứ đó cùng ngày Iran đã gửi tới các nước chó ai một một mề sức hạm nhân,
nhằm ngăn chạm cả năng bị có hòa sơ chế tại áprat các biển pháp xin phát trong đó xe Iran
còn đình. Ý ra không thể là bên dưới lất chữ trình nhẹm từ gồm để sất chế.